what's going on everybody and welcome to
another Raspberry Pi tutorial in this
tutorial what we're going to be doing is
introducing the GPIO pins on the
Raspberry Pi how to use them and all
that so what we have here is one
breadboard to male-to-female jumper
wires one resistor the resistor should
be somewhere between like 301 K ohms and
then an LED light this one's yellow it
really doesn't matter what color you
choose though and basically what the
GPIO pins do for us is they allow us
GPIO stands for general purpose input
output and it allows us to either send
out a signal either high or low so just
a binary signal out or receive a signal
back in and there's all kinds of ways
that we can manipulate that to have a
lot more dynamism to it
now the GPIO pins are labeled for us and
I'm going to pull up this image from
Adafruit and these are the GPIO pins
above that kind of gray line that's the
older PI's and if you have one of the
more later versions you'll have all 40
pins and you can go all the way down
there towards the bottom of that image
now the way these are oriented if we go
back to here it's as if it's the same
way this pi is oriented in this image
sure this video right here so that
translates directly to these pins here
so the top leftmost pin is 3.3 volts and
then the two top right most pins or your
5 volt outputs now what we're going to
do is we're going to rig up a simple LED
light that will just turn on when we ask
it to via our program to do that to
create the circuit we're going to be
using this breadboard here so this is
breadboard the way that it works is
basically all on these edges here
sometimes you'll have like two rows and
breadboards will look a little different
but they're generally going to look
something like this and these are
connected vertically basically so by
column I suppose you could say and then
you've got these middle bits each of
these are connected by row so for
example let's say
this this spot here is connected to this
one is connected to this one and so on
but these are not directly connected to
these you'll connect them yourselves and
then like this one is closest one I
suppose this one is not connected to
this one or this one but this one is
connected to this one so to help you
understand that even further I've just
kind of circled or squared some examples
of ones that are already connected but
of course you can connect them yourself
with jumper wires or will use the
resistor to do it and so on and then
even the LED bulb will use so what we
want to do is wire this all together so
here's a quick diagram of the actual
wiring that we're going to do now this
is not a real wiring diagram by any
means but I know whenever I was first
starting out the last thing I wanted to
see was a wiring diagram I wanted
something a little more obvious to me so
basically what I've done here is this
green is the Raspberry Pi The Cult the
filled in boxes by color or the actual
jumper wires so black to black and so on
and then the resistor is this like blue
blob and the LEDs right here and it's
labeled and all that so it's just like
super simple so coming back to our
Raspberry Pi now let's go ahead and
connect everything let me just pop up
the diagram there so it's actually kind
of a little hard to see if your screens
not very big at least that yellow so the
yellow here is armed basically six pins
down and then three pins down for the
the ground so if you want you can take a
screenshot of this also you can go to
the text-based version of this tutorial
and save this image it's always good to
have an extra one around so anyway yeah
ground here the third pin down on the
right and then we'll also be using GPIO
pin 18 also just for the record these
are the Broadcom names it's a little
unfortunate the Raspberry Pi has like
the board names for the pins and that's
just like the physical location
basically of the pin you can use the
board name tens or the Broadcom names
and the Broadcom that's the processor
that we're using that's the actual chip
that's how it recognizes those pins
that's the name of that pin according to
the chip so
we're going to use the Broadcom names
okay so let's go ahead and wire this up
just going to connect here this this
blue cable will be my ground so we'll go
ahead and connect everything up
nothing's plugged in so it doesn't
really matter the order that we do this
but yes so we'll go ahead connect ground
here and then the female end for the
actual led here and then ground we'll
connect right here
and then we'll use the resistor
[Music]
and then next to the resistor will be
the LED bolt and now one thing to take
note of let's see if you can see that
you notice that there's one end that's
longer than the other
not all LED bulbs are going to have that
but when you do have that the positive
end is the longer end so since this is
the ground and we actually want the
negative end to be on that side so we'll
go ahead and plug that in if for
whatever reason your circuit doesn't
flip them around you probably just made
a simple mistake otherwise the bulb
could be burnt out there's all kinds of
uses 20 would work or your circuits bad
or whatever okay once we've done that
now we can just plug in for the actual
resistors kind of touching we don't want
them to be touching I don't want metal
to metal there now in reality you'd
actually trim that resistor down so it
wasn't sticking up so much but yeah make
sure the resistor isn't directly
touching say the positive end of the the
GPIO cord anyway or the LED rather okay
so I've got everything hooked up and
again it's according to this diagram if
you need more pictures I've got some
better pictures of the actual physical
wiring of this thing in the text-based
version so if you're still confused or
whatever definitely check those out but
yeah so now let's go ahead I'm going to
plug in the Raspberry Pi we're going to
fire it up and then we're going to get
to the actual code to make this light
turn on off all right with the Raspberry
Pi all connected turned on I'm in the
terminal via SSH let's go ahead and
change the directory to the desktop and
also let's just make sure we've got our
PI GPIO chances are you already have it
but let's just make sure so sudo apt -
get installed Python
- RPI GPIO and we already have it so
it's no problems so now I'm going to go
ahead and do is we're going to nano LED
example dot PI and now we're regulated
do is import RPI dot all caps GPIO now
mine the caps let's capital R capital P
lowercase I dot all caps GPIO
import that gpio then we're going to
also import time and then now we're
going to do is GPIO to set mode GPIO
GPIO dot DCM so the DCM is short for
Broadcom the other option is if you
wanted board names but I'm going to use
the BCM Broadcom names because I just
think it makes more sense and we just
want to make sure we're using the same
names as as we think we are
anybody say you want to want to mess up
the pins so now we've done that we're
ready to set up the pin so like like I
was saying before our pin that we
connected to is pin 18 for let me pull
it up here so we connected that third
from the top right ground you could have
connected at any of the grounds it's not
a big deal which one but our actual pin
that's going to send an output signal to
that LED bulb to actually turn it on is
going to be GPIO pin number 18 again you
could have plugged it into any of the
other GPIO ports it's not essential that
you do the exact same port or pin rather
as I do anyway what I'm going to do now
is GPIO set up and we're going to set up
pin number 18 and we're going to call
that a GPIO dot out it can also take an
input so it could be GPIO in now we're
going to do is GPIO whoops all caps GPIO
dot output and we're going to output the
pin 18 and we're going to output a high
signal it could be a GPIO too high or
low those are the two signals that you
can output from your GPIO so we're going
to do high and then we'll go ahead and
time dot sleep we'll do five seconds and
then we'll do GPIO output again depend
18 GPIO dot look so it's a low signal
and then when we're all done let's go
ahead and run GPIO duck cleanup and that
should be everything that we need so
let's go ahead and exit that safe yes
cool let's go ahead and run Python led
example dot PI and let me just pull my
screen over here so I can make sure that
shows up on camera no problem go ahead
and run that hard to tell with that
yellow light but it is on and I think
these are five seconds yeah and now it's
off so hopefully yours turned on and off
minded there okay so this is like a
really quick basic example of using the
GPIO that's one way to send out a value
now what we're going to do is use that
distance sensor to actually input bring
back in some data from our from a sensor
so that's what we're going to be doing
in the next tutorial a little slightly
more complex setup but it's not too bad
so that's what we're going to be doing
the next tutorial if you have questions
comments concerns or whatever up to this
point feel free to leave them below
otherwise I will see you in the next
tutorial